Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier.
And welcome to Nighttime Visitor!
Now this game is an indie horror game made for a game jam a while back,
and let me set the scene for ya,
you're working late at an office late at night when you suddenly get a visitor of unknown origins(oooooo spooky)
whose only mission is to murder you dead through strangulation of the butt.
That's all I know about the game because I literally know nothing else about the game,
except it kinda takes place in an office...
Now the reason I-
I saw this a while ago on itch.io, uh, and I was gonna play it, but I-
(interrupted by telephone ringing)
Oh...
Mark in game: Hello~?
Phone Man: Oh, hello~?
Phone Guy: Hey this is Alex. I heard you were working late tonight~.
Alex: I was just callin' to say that, um~..
Alex: COMMIN' TO GET YA XD *laughing*
Mark: *laughing* Is that really the-
*laughing* Is that really the basic premise of this game?
I'm sorry to laugh at it... But... he's... COMIN' TO GET ME! HEHEHEHE!
He- He's COMIN' TO GET YA!
He's like Chucky, he's gonna stab me in the ankles until I'm dead.
He can only reach as high as my butt; so he's the perfect crazed butt stabber!
(*mutters under his breath) Alright, so...
Anyway that threw me for a loop there. I was actually- ?????? - Oh yeah, I was saying uh,
The reason I didn't play it before was because when I first took a look at it, it seemed very simplistic
Uh, so I didn't- I didn't play it right away; but a lot of you guys have been recommending it to me.
And also I realized that I was biased because
*creepy ass mumbling*
Sorry...
... Hello??
Mail room?
*Mark knocking*
HELLO??
MAY I COME IN??
I'm co- *phone rings*
Hello?
Hi!
*Creepy heavy breathing on phone*
Could you not do that? (Marks face)
Could you not do that, please?
Could you not breathe in my ear please?
*Mark knocking* HELLO? MAIL ROOM I'VE GOT A PROBLEM!
Someone's- oh- there we go I guess -
I guess we're done here...
Okay goodbye!
Jesus.
What am I-
*weird noise and mumbling*
Hello?
Okay, so I don't exactly know what I'm supposed to be doing...
*Mark knocking*
I- I- I mean in most of these indie horror games the only objective is to not die.
Which is as good an objective as anyone playing in these games.
*Mark knocking* DAVIS? HELLO!
*chuckles* why am I knocking on doors?
*knocking* House? I need a doctor so badly
*sad chuckle* my jokes are terrible
Dunn?
Heh, everyone's DUNN with this video
(ba dum tiss)
Okay... anyway
*mumbling and creepy noises*
*whispers* what the fuck is that?
what is that?
I don't know what that is
*phone rings*
Hi
*More heavy breathing Chucky butt stabber is back*
OH THAnK yOu
I was /hoping/ it was gonna be the breathing
I was really hoping
Okay
Alright, bye then
okay, recieved call... YEAH I know about that
oh man
So what am supposed to be doing here?
Oo whats that? (Das ist eine Tür Mark)
Hello
Hello?
No? okay
Alright then
Oo that- hi..
Who ar- WHAT ARE YOU?
DON'T COME NEAR ME
*Screaming* OH GOD AAAA
*laughing* He is- He is the size of Chucky
Wow
and was he holding a cell phone?
oh
oH
oh I'm sor- whoa
oOh my god
*nervous chuckle*
okay, man
this game is full of surprises
So is this why that guy-
he looked like he was drawn with crayon
aw what is this place?
What is this?
Oh man
urg
Horrifying
(*Markipoo mumbles) hang on I...
(*mumbles again) wutizdis
aw man
Oh, I tHOUGHT THAT WAS A WALL
okAY NEVER MIND THEN IT'S NOT A WALL, NOt a wall at all
and I'm guessing those are skyscrapers in the-
-what is happening?
okay
Yeah, this is why I don't let my biased stop me from playing games
or at least I shouldn't because-
-they can come up with really interesting things like this
and
*singing?* I dunno what this is but I like it
Hello?
*gasp* aM I BECOMING THE KILLER?
is it like an endless loop of becoming the killer?
the hell is that?
*phone dialing* (*lots of suspenseful background ambiance)
oOokay
is that the end?
oh-
oh, no I'm back!
*phone rings*
oH GOD NO
It's like a Stanley Parable thing
Hello?
Alex (from the start): Hey this is Alex. I heard you were working late tonight
Alex: I was just callin' to say that, um..
Alex & Mark: COMMIN' TO GET YA
Mark: NYEHEHE
Okay, thanks Alex
You're a doll, I love you
oh, no signal
okay
So I can't call him.
you move slower with your phone out?
OH
Have I been doing that the whole time? I have no idea
So
Obviously I'm supposed to avoid him
but what am i supposed to do?
Just get out?
whY WON'T ANYONE HELP ME?
*knocking* heLLO?
I NEED HELP
IS THERE ANYTHING DOWN THERE?
PROBably not
no one want's so help me :'(
I'm scared and alone :(
*knocking*
I'm scared
and alone
I mean I have you guys with me
and that's of great comfort to me
and I appreciate you guys being here
and I love you very dearly
-but yoU'RE NOT GONNA HELP ME FROM DYING A HORRIBLE DEATH
*phone rings*
Hi
Do I need to answer this?
*chucky the crazed butt stabber heavy breathing and shit*
hi
it's the same thing
it's the same thing, why do I need to talk to you?
oH GOD DAMMIT
*sounded like chica fro FNAF*
what was that?
uh
I dunno why this game's givin' me the heebie jeebies-
this is - I know the monster is tiny
oh god-
oh god, what is this
whAT IS THIS?
WHat- whERE AM I
oh god- what was that
was that something important?
i dunno what that was
oO I dont know what that was
oO
oO thats not ominous at all
ah- what's happening?
oh sh- I thought it was getting dark
I tho - I thought my vision was going black
I thought I was passing out
AUrgh
aleX IS COmiNG tO StaB mE iN THe buTt
sTAHP IT
uhh
aW GOD DAMMIT
I SAW AN EXIT SIGN
WHAT AM I DOING
oOH HELLO, HI
it is the outside
wait what does that sign say?
what?
exit?
exIT THAT WAY?
buT I JUST CAME FROM THAT WAY
Exit which way???!
I feel like i'm just wandering in goddamn circles
over and over again
which- which way?
that way?
ugh goddamit i did go in a big goddamn circle, I dID
fuckin' ugh
I knew I did,
I knEW I did
where does this lead?.. whoa
*whispering* what is that?
whoa what is this?
AAUGH FUCKING GOD
*sighs*
GODDAMIT
Where wAS I GOING THE SIGNS WERE ALL ILLOGICAL!?
THE SIGNS WERE JUST GOING IN GODDAMN CIRCLES
thERe wAS No eXIT >:(
tHERE WAS NO EXIT AT ALL >:(
IT WAS ALL A BUNCH OF LIES >:(
IT WAS A BUNCH OF LIEs
it was just nothing but LIES
endLESS ENDLESS LIES
I-  I swear
where else could I have gone?
I was- there was like
There was like straight paths for a long time
and then, it was just looping circles
and then- and then that did! Like I had a choice to go around that way and it was just one big looping circle.
Like, what else could you have done? there was nothing to do!
*heavy sighs*
I dunno-
I dunno what else I could've done
I need to look up, to see if this is even beatable, hang on
I dont- where's my phon-
hang on. I'll be right back
OHHH MYYY GODD! :O
OHH MY FUCKING GOD! :O
I WAS RIGHT THERE!
I WAS AT THE END!
I- OH MY GOD
ShUT. THE. FUCK. UP ALEX!
I WAS LITERALLY-
- LITERALLY, I WAS INChes from the exit
I was right there
I went ALL THAT WAY!
AND THat took awhile 'cause we don't exactly go fast here
that took a long time, I was right there
and apparently, I just got lucky
that I didn't get killed
so, like that- that beginners luck
that one shining brief moment- I could have won
and yet I didn't becAUSE IM AN ASS!
I mean it's not my fault; I didn't know. but-
oh I wa- you do not know
if i beat this, and I hope I do, but you never know with this thing
If I beat this, you guys will see exactly how close I was (Phone ringing)
Hello, (Even more breathing) are you just- you're just breathing. Okay.
So that's nothing but breathing.
There's nothing to those calls...
but breathing
which is lovely.
Lovely breathing by the way but...
not what i'm looking for
Oh jeezums! Was it this long!?
I don't know if those sounds actually mean anything
or if my death is actually impending
*whispering* did i take a left here?
oh- uh- i think i might have
I don't think I did, wait no- hang on
AAugh I didn't
uuhh
im such an idiot
I don't remember the way that I went :(
what was that?
God something just-
-oh, down here
this looks familiar
okay, so I think I went down here
ooh, okay
so
Ah yeah the ominous looking hallway, that's right I remember this
So this is the right way
okay so, you see these windows here?
these windows?
these windows!?
yeah you remember them?! yOU REMEMEBER THE WINDOWS?
I might- I might actually do this.
okay, so this is good
I might actually do this
we shall see
IT WAS RIGHT HERE
I GOT MISLED BY THAT SIGN BACK THERE
THERE'S ANOTHER SIGN OVER HERE
AND ITS RIGHT THERE
I WAS RIGHT THERE
ON MY FIRst like, real try
my first try, well obviously I had no idea
YEEEAHH!
I WAS RIGHT THERE!
I WAS RIGHT THERE (STAHP REPEATING YOURSELF)
OHH MAN
I congratulate you for escaping that place.Thank you for playing this silly thing. Happy Halloween
So
That was Nighttime Visitor
I
Somehow
Navigated the entire game, through sheer blind luck... anD THEN I WAS MISLED!
AT THE END BY BULLSHITTERY!
I should've trusted the sign
Well I've been trusting the signs before that like-
goddamnit, either way. So... Im pissed about that but
I still did it
so we're done
so thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought of this game
it was really interesting, because the creepy factor was really there like-
lurking through those hallways like-
'cause the first time I went through I died right away like- right in that opening hallway
like i died, very, very quickly
uh, but, it was just weird because I thought it was gonna be much more like,
deadly than that, and it was just like this impending sense of dread
going down to another hallway and being like
'oh shit there's more'
so, that was pretty well made about it, I did like that a lot
(OUTRO MUSIC INITIATE) but then again, the graphics are pretty simplistic, but you shouldn't criticize too much
so, thank you everybody so much for watching and as always, I will see you in the next video
BUH BYE